hey folks taking you behind the scenes
today our campus is growing we're not in
just one location here anymore where the
studio is we're now in multiple places
around this building cost a couple
streets here and there because the team
is growing and so we have a bus driver
named Donald the guy's amazing he drives
around all day long moving our team to
and fro so they get to their car back to
this building back to their building
whatever it is but today unfortunately
Donald couldn't be with us and at Ramsey
solutions we all have to step up
sometimes and wear different hats so
good news we have a guest bus driver
today who's going to go on the rounds
and I'm going to take you with us so
here's our guest bus driver hey Dave how
about that I got my hat on man I'm ready
this is cool we're about ready to go to
Lambeau lunch people and what that is is
this is once a month the entire team
5:30 and growing gets together and folks
we're going over to Dover building and
this is just a couple streets over bus
driver doesn't have a seat belt on yeah
they even have a seat belt on but our
team has no idea that Dave's about ready
to pick them up so this is gonna be
great
I've been wanting to drive this thing
since I got it how does it handle like a
yacht
this is fine I think you should show
Conor right here so there's Connor wing
encounters on our video team if you
watch backseat drivers this is what I'm
normally seen because I can't talk and
concentrate from where I'm going so I
have to have a lead car so that I don't
get lost with our guest that's the magic
of video that Omaha did not need a lead
car to drive one mile to our other
authors it not so here we come we're
coming up here on the line of people
here we got about five or six folks that
are waiting to go to Lambeau lunch look
at them they're having a blast no idea
that Dave's rolling up oh I can't wait
more people standing in the lobby
want to go let's go to Atlanta
see take a seat is this a normal like
seating capacity at Lambeau at lunchtime
or is this like everyday yeah but they
didn't know who was driving it probably
it probably would have thinned out
considerable should we like no
four-wheel y'all want to go
four-wheeling you guys want to go
off-road I noticed he didn't want to get
on they can't stop you from singing
all right dave has transported estate
for to Lampa watch
you